J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour et bonne année 2025. Mieux vaut tard que jamais. Je reçois aujourd'hui un ancien juge d'instruction, Michel Claise, qui s'est spécialisé dans la criminalité financière.
Il est aujourd'hui retraité, mais il est également auteur et essayiste. Et ça tombe bien, puisqu'il vient de sortir un livre où il fait l'état des lieux de la criminalité dans le monde.
Ça s'appelle Combattre la criminalité, une urgence démocratique et c'est dispo chez Racine. Il est aujourd'hui conseiller communal à Forest et c'est là où j'habite.
Donc c'était l'occasion. Bonne écoute. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Michel Claise. Bonjour Michel Claise.
Bonjour.
Michel Claise, pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas, vous avez été donc avocat pendant vingt ans. Vous avez ensuite été surtout juge d'instruction pendant vingt-trois ans.
Vous êtes également l'auteur de quatorze romans, puis deux essais plus récemment. Vous êtes enseignant à l'ESSEC, maître de conférences à Solvay, expert au Conseil de l'Europe.
Vous intervenez également au programme international à Strasbourg en ce qui concerne la lutte contre la criminalité financière.
Et on vous connaît bien sûr pour les questions de criminalité à col blanc, qu'on va avoir-
Mmh.
...l'occasion d'explorer ensemble, les questions de... voilà, on a notamment parlé en 2014 de l'inculpation du patron d'UBS Belgique, puis la banque HSBC,
le patron des patrons qui est arrivé derrière les barreaux à Savoux, Luc Van Steenkiste.
Vous avez travaillé sur les dossiers des Panama Papers, des Swiss Leaks, des Football Leaks et de manière générale, les questions de corruption.
Ça fait fameuse liste de sujets qu'on va pouvoir éventuellement explorer ensemble.
Revenons à l'instant sur la question des questions de corruption, puisque c'est notamment sur ces questions qu'on vous a entendu intervenir dans la presse.
Alors, je vais vous poser la question simplement, tout bêtement : qu'est-ce qui explique, selon vous, votre efficacité dans ces dossiers ?
Puisque quand on lit la presse, on a l'impression que vous étiez particulièrement, particulièrement talentueux.
Oh, c'est gentil. Alors, je sais pas si je suis talentueux, mais en tout cas, j'ai des bonnes équipes de policiers.
Sans bons policiers, on n'arrive à rien. Alors, la corruption est une infraction qui est particulièrement difficile à détecter.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous avez deux personnes qui s'entendent, le corrompu et le corrupteur. Et parfois, il y a un petit élément qui dépasse, qui fait que cela vient à la connaissance du, ou du parquet-
Mmh.
...ou des policiers. Alors-
Ça touche toujours une petite bavure de l'auteur du crime ?
Oui, il y a toujours une pe-- heureusement qu'il y a des petites bavures de temps en temps, parce que c'est peut-être une des infractions financières les plus difficiles à détecter. Alors,
les affaires de corruption, j'en ai connu quelques-unes, effectivement. Et c'est surtout dans la manière dont elles sont amenées dans le cabinet du juge d'instruction qu'on sait déjà si on a une chance d'obtenir quelque chose ou pas.
Mais disons que d'une manière générale, il faut de l'imagination, un peu de chance, beaucoup d'audace pour oser s'attaquer de temps en temps à certains qui ont des grands noms dans le domaine de la corruption.
Et puis, parfois un flagrant délit, ce qui-
Mmh.
...est déjà arrivé. Et puis, alors on boucle un dossier.
Vous parlez d'audace. On pourrait mettre ça en comparaison avec des pressions, avec des craintes.
Est-ce que vous vous estimez que vous avez été audacieux dans le sens où vous faisiez face à des risques ?
Ben, des risques, je vais pas dire qu'il n'y en avait pas, parce que de temps en temps, évidemment, il y avait des sonnettes d'alarme qui étaient tirées par l'Office central de l'appréciation de la menace.
C'était-- d'ailleurs, ce sont des moments qui sont difficiles à vivre pour les magistrats. C'est pas très agréable d'être mis sous protection à ces moments-là, mais disons que ce n'est pas le risque qui fait qu'on ne va pas enquêter.
Moi, je me suis jamais vraiment senti en danger.
Mmh.
Alors, de pression, je dois vous avouer que dans ma carrière, j'en ai pas eu. J'ai fait l'objet d'attaques, j'ai fait l'objet de menaces, mais je n'ai jamais fait l'objet de pression.
J'ai parfois constaté certaines, comment dire, certaines intrusions de l'exécutif dans le monde judiciaire, mais fort peu.
Je pense que nous vivons encore dans une société relativement démocratique, ce qui en soi est déjà un succès quand on pense dans le monde au nombre de pays qui ne sont plus du tout dans la démocratie.
On peut encore un peu s'en revendiquer.
Mmh. On aura l'occasion d'en reparler plus tard dans l'interview, mais il y a notamment eu une intrusion dans votre appartement au moment de l'affaire Qatar Gate.
Donc, il y a quand même quelques exemples, je pense, de-
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Moins agréables.
Donc ça, c'était assez amusant, si je puis dire, parce que c'était d'une maladresse par rapport à ceux qui l'ont fait.
Donc, on s'est aperçu que, enfin, c'est tout bête. J'ai deux serrures à ma porte d'entrée.
Il y en a une qui est une serrure de sécurité, mais dont je n'ai plus la clé depuis des années.
OK.
Et puis, c'est tout simplement cette serrure était fermée, ce qui était totalement impossible.
Ah oui.
Donc, il y a eu une intrusion.
Mais donc de quelqu'un qui possédait la clé alors ?
Non. Vous pensez qu'il faut posséder une clé pour entrer chez quelqu'un ?
Ah, je sais pas, je suis naïf.
Mon serrurier avec qui j'ai travaillé pendant des années, il lui suffisait parfois de regarder la porte pour qu'elle s'ouvre, tellement il était habile de ses mains.
C'est-- d'accord, je possède, je pense, une meilleure porte que vous alors. Mais...
Oh, surtout pas. La mienne, c'est une vraie passoire.
Très bien. Donc des questions de pression. Voilà, vous estimiez qu'il fallait une certaine créativité, vous disiez.
Mmh-mmh.
Et quoi ? Est-ce que vous avez le sentiment d'être particulièrement créatif, que c'est quelque chose qui vous a servi dans ce travail-là ?
C'est un travail collectif. Donc une enquête, ça se mène avec des policiers, de temps en temps
avec le parquet dans les très très gros dossiers, parce qu'on ne peut pas concevoir de ne pas mêler le parquet à l'enquête en vue de maintenir une cohésion dans ce qui seront plus tard les poursuites.
Le juge d'instruction ne poursuit pas, il instruit. Et la créativité, c'est une réflexion globale. Il faut de temps en temps se dire : tiens, moi, ça m'est arrivé dans un dossier où personne n'y a cru.
On dit : écoutez, puisque les personnes poursuivies disent que la solution se trouve dans un pays extrêmement difficile d'accès, en l'espèce, c'était le Pakistan.
Et si nous faisions une commission rogatoire au Pakistan, sachant qu'on n'avait quasi aucune chance d'avoir une réponse du Pakistan pour se rendre sur place.
Pas du tout. Non seulement nous avons reçu une réponse, nous avons été sur place et effectivement, nous avons trouvé le pot aux roses quand nous étions au Pakistan.
Vous voyez, la créativité, c'était de se dire que finalement, et si on tentait quand même le coup ? Eh ben, ça a marché.
De ne pas être trop présomptueux dans son enquête.
Je vais me permettre de rappeler pour les personnes qui n'auraient peut-être pas forcément le vocabulaire ou les connaissances judiciaires, donc juge d'instruction, c'est-à-dire que vous n'étiez pas,
vous ne jugiez pas de l'affaire en elle-même, mais vous étiez en charge de l'enquête, d'objectiver les faits.
Moitié policier, moitié magistrat. Le magistrat est chargé de la légalité des actes posés. Et le côté policier du juge d'instruction, c'est participer à l'enquête elle-même.
De temps en temps, je n'ai pas fait que des affaires financières, bien sûr. Quand on était de service de droit commun, nous, les juges financiers, nous descendons sur place.
Nous allons chercher les cadavres quand il s'agit d'un assassinat et nous cherchons bien entendu les assassins. Et de temps en temps, on les trouvait.
Non, je pense d'ailleurs qu'on les a tous trouvés.
Tous ?
Il est extrêmement rare qu'on ne parvient pas à dévoiler, à trouver l'identité du criminel.
C'est pas pour ça qu'on arrête. S'il est parti dans des pays exotiques, c'est difficile de mettre la main dessus.
Mais en général, les enquêtes sont à un très haut pourcentage résolues.
C'est-- alors, je comptais en parler plus tard, mais ça me permet de forker sur, faire le lien avec un autre élément qui sont les, la question des fameuses banques de données.
Puisque donc, en Belgique, on est assez prudent vis-à-vis de ces questions. Donc, on a des banques de données, par exemple, pour ce qui est des agressions sexuelles, pour ce qui est des meurtres, ce genre de délits,
mais pas, par exemple, pour la criminalité,
disons, plus légère, vol à l'étalage, etc.
Là où, par exemple, chez nos voisins, ils sont beaucoup plus radicaux en France, à ce niveau-là. Est-ce que du coup, voilà, vous avez en tête quelques exemples de criminels qu'on n'a pas pu attraper ?
Est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que...
Sans doute. En tout cas, en ce qui me concerne, c'est l'inverse. Parce que j'avais été en charge d'un dossier, c'est une vieille dame qui, dans le quartier des Marolles, avait été, alors là, ben assassinée pour la voler.
Et donc, on n'avait que très peu d'éléments d'enquête qui nous permettaient d'identifier les auteurs. On avait une vague photo,
dans l'immeuble de deux personnes qui rentrent, qui ne sont pas des habitants de l'immeuble et qui vont sortir trois quarts d'heure après avec une valise.
Capuchés, j'imagine.
Non, on voyait quand même un peu leur visage, mais c'était une très mauvaise qualité. Mais quoi qu'il en soit, c'est pas parce qu'on a leur visage qu'on peut en faire quelque chose.
Ici, c'était impossible. Et donc on avait très peu d'éléments. Et alors, il fallait donc procéder aux méthodes traditionnelles.
Donc cette personne avait le visage entouré de papiers, vous savez, qu'on met sur les caisses quand on déménage, là, ces papiers bruns, là, pour fermer les caisses, avec des chaussettes dans sa bouche.
Donc, on l'a tué en l'étouffant. Et donc, toute l'enquête a porté, puisqu'on avait fait tous les caméras, les tentatives de vérification des utilisations de GSM, d'antennes, etc. Rien.
Et donc on a travaillé sur les ADN. Alors en travaillant sur l'ADN,
c'est pas du tout comme dans Les Experts Miami, où on prend la petite culotte de la fille violée, on la met dedans, puis boum, vous avez la photo du gars dans les trente secondes qui sort et
une minute après, Horatio Caine peut l'écouter dans son bureau.
C'est pas comme ça que ça marche. Ça demande des analyses qui sont extrêmement longues, avec des moyens quand même qui sont pas exceptionnels non plus en termes de rapidité.
Et pendant un an, j'ai enquêté millimètre par millimètre sur-- j'ordonne donc aux policiers de soumettre au laboratoire millimètre par millimètre.
Et puis, à un certain moment, on détecte une part d'ADN. Il faut dix-sept éléments pour constituer un ADN entier et donc une reconnaissance possible.
Et donc j'en avais un, puis j'en ai eu trois, puis j'en ai eu cinq, puis j'en ai eu dix. C'est un ADN mâle. Donc là, forcément, c'est vraisemblablement celui de, peut-être de la personne qui a procédé à l'agression.
Et puis plus rien. Et donc à un certain moment, mon policier arrive en disant : « Écoute, voilà, il reste une micro goutte de sang qu'on a détectée ».
Alors, je comprends, ça a coûté cher. J'ai dit : « Moi, si on n'analyse pas cette micro goutte de sang, jamais je ne dormirai ».
Et là, l'ADN complet apparaît. Et donc là, j'ai une identification possible. J'envoie en Europe la lecture de l'ADN partout et c'est la France, c'est Paris qui va me répondre en disant : « Nous connaissons la personne que vous cherchez ». Ah, je dis : «
Pour quel motif ? » Vol à l'étalage. Et c'est là que j'apprends effectivement qu'en France, dès qu'on a fait l'objet d'une poursuite et d'une identification, il existe une banque de données, même pour le vol à l'étalage, qui est retenue.
Eh bien grâce à ça, j'ai pu identifier. Il a été libéré, mais on a fait ce qu'on appelle des utilisations téléphoniques de vérification géographique, là où se trouve le GSM, comme il avait son numéro de GSM et sa carte SIM.
Et on l'a arrêté. Et j'ai eu le deuxième très facilement. Ils sont passés devant la cour d'assises et ils ont été condamnés pour vol, avec le meurtre pour faciliter celui-ci.
Donc, c'est-à-dire une des plus hautes infractions du code pénal. Donc, vous voyez que là, la France, oui, eh ben ça fonctionne, ils ont une banque de données générale.
Et en Belgique, comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure, c'est limité aux faits sexuels et de crimes de sang.
Alors, vous occupez une position assez particulière puisque vous êtes passé donc du rôle de juge d'instruction, voilà, magistrat, moitié magistrat, moitié policier, comme vous le disiez, à un rôle politique.
Vous aviez l'ambition, on va en parler un peu plus tard, mais l'ambition de siéger à la Chambre des représentants avec Défi.
Ça n'a pas été le cas, finalement.
La question, on peut malgré tout se la poser, la question de l'équilibre entre la vie privée, la collecte des données centralisées, donc dans le chef de la police fédérale, contre, voilà, l'intérêt-
Mh.
des forces de police dans le cadre d'une enquête. Est-ce que vous auriez tendance à défendre le statu quo dans la façon dont c'est aujourd'hui en Belgique ?
C'est-à-dire qu'on est prudent dans la collecte des données, on ne les partage pas forcément, voilà, dès qu'il y a un vol à l'étalage, on ne se permet pas de récolter de façon permanente les données génétiques de la personne.
Ou bien est-ce que vous, au contraire, vous enviez totalement la France et vous voudriez qu'on fasse comme eux ?
Je vous reprends d'abord sur un point. Me présentant troisième sur la liste Défi, peut-on dire que j'ai l'ambition d'être au fédéral ?
La réponse est non. Moi, mon ambition aussi, c'était de mener une campagne politique pour mettre en évidence tous les problèmes qui se posaient en termes et de justice et de justice financière.
Vous étiez sur les listes sans vouloir vraiment siéger ?
C'est pas une question de-- j'aurais été ravi de siéger.
Oui.
J'ai fait une campagne dans lequel,
à mon sens, il y avait une possibilité de le faire. Mon résultat d'ailleurs était quand même assez satisfaisant dans la mesure où il y en a, en tout cas, il y en a deux qui siègent au Parlement avec moins de voix que je n'en ai obtenues.
Ça, c'est le jeu des partis.
Six mille sept cents voix de préférence.
Oui, quasiment, oui, c'est ça, plus que ça même. Et donc un petit peu plus dans les six mille sept cents. Et donc, c'est pas mal du tout pour un début, mais en réalité, bon, vous pensez bien que c'est pas un parti qui va non plus,
mais c'est un excellent parti pour moi
qui correspond à mes valeurs.
Je reviens. Alors, en termes, à votre question,
est-ce qu'il faut un statu quo ou pas ? C'est une question extrêmement importante dans la mesure où, un, nous disposons d'une protection des données de la vie privée, le RGPD, qui est quand même bien faite.
Et donc, nous avons de temps en temps effectivement des failles, mais ces failles, on peut effectivement les combler.
La situation actuelle, quand vous dites : « Dans l'intérêt de la police, faut-il augmenter ? » C'est pas dans l'intérêt de la police qu'on le fait.
C'est dans l'intérêt de l'enquête, de la recherche de la vérité, de la recherche d'éventuels coupables. On--
La seule chose qui pourrait être inquiétante, et nous connaissons quand même une société mondiale et une société européenne,
qui connaît actuellement des grands bouleversements sur le plan politique, il est évident qu'à partir du moment où on crée des banques de données aujourd'hui dans un pays qui connaît la démocratie
et qu'il y a un renversement de la démocratie, cela pourrait être utilisé, évidemment, à des fins autres que des fins d'enquêtes criminelles.
Très mauvaise question.
Ça, c'est un danger. Mais d'un autre côté, aujourd'hui, avec le système démocratique, sachant que toutes les mesures qui touchent la vie privée se font sous le contrôle d'un magistrat qui doit motiver.
Si c'est mal motivé ou motivé à tort, tout élément qu'on découvre est écarté de l'enquête. Ça vaut pour les écoutes téléphoniques comme ça vaudrait pour une recherche d'ADN.
À partir de ce moment-là, moi, je serais favorable, effectivement, à étendre l'existence des banques de données à ce stade en étant particulièrement attentif à l'évolution de la société.
Mais quand je cite cet exemple, c'est pour ça que j'ai été jusqu'au bout, parce que je savais que vous alliez me poser la question.
Et donc, on va jusqu'au bout dans cet exemple de cette dame dont on a découvert les assassins. S'il n'y avait pas eu l'ADN en France, j'aurais jamais découvert les assassins.
Mh. Oui, mais c'est... Bon. C'est, voilà, effectivement, on aurait envie de dire : « Bah tout peut, on peut tout justifier.
» La fin justifie les moyens. On peut justifier n'importe quelle sorte de banque de données à partir de ce moment-là.
Non, je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous.
Non, non, c'est-
Parce que-
C'est juste la conclusion à laquelle vous arrivez.
Non, pas, non. La fin ne justifie pas les moyens. C'est la manière d'arriver à la fin qui doit être, à la fin, c'est-à-dire in fine-
Mh.
Que les choses doivent être évidemment maintenues dans leur existence actuelle par l'obligation de vérification du pouvoir judiciaire, qui, je vous rappelle, est indépendant du pouvoir policier et inversement.
Vous avez le ministère de l'Intérieur, le ministère de la Justice d'autre part.
Mais comme vous le disiez.
Mais évidemment, le risque, c'est un détournement. Est-ce que les policiers aujourd'hui ont l'occasion de détourner les données qu'on obtient à des fins policières sans passer par un magistrat ?
Oui. Et je l'ai dénoncé dans la presse. Il y a un cas. C'est notamment les caméras de rue. Et donc vous avez des cas, des caméras de rue qui sont placées en vue de la circulation routière et la détection des infractions éventuelles.
Eh bien, figurez-vous que celles-ci peuvent être utilisées par les policiers dans le cadre d'enquêtes sans passer par un magistrat, ce qui est inacceptable.
Moi, je l'ai dénoncé. Mais bon, en attendant, c'est le cas aujourd'hui et je n'aime pas cela.
Oui, oui, oui. C'était assez bluffant, là où on en est arrivé. Je vais me permettre de revenir, donc, sur les questions de corruption.
Oui.
Puisqu'on a fait un petit détour sur les questions de vie privée. Est-ce que vous diriez qu'il y a aujourd'hui une aggravation des questions de corruption dans l'Union européenne ?
Mais oui. Et je me pose la question de savoir, d'abord, ça a toujours existé. Est-ce que c'est une aggravation ?
Ou bien, tout simplement, est-ce que nous avons trouvé des moyens de la détecter plus facilement ? Il y a les deux qui peuvent se joindre.
Mais je pense qu'il existe, de par la situation difficile que nous connaissons aujourd'hui d'un point de vue économique, une aggravation de celle-ci.
Parce que la corruption, il faut pas nécessairement s'imaginer que ça se fait au niveau du Parlement européen. La corruption, c'est aussi dans les communes.
Écoutez, moi, j'ai vécu un dossier dans une commune à Bruxelles où les fonctionnaires faisaient des faux permis de conduire en moyennant des montants ridicules,
au profit de personnes venant de l'étranger qui sollicitaient d'avoir un permis de conduire.
C'est une petite corruption, direz-vous, sur le plan des montants. Le montant global des intermédiaires entre les fonctionnaires de
la commune et les personnes qui achetaient les fameux permis de conduire, et parfois aussi des cartes d'identité, etc.,
se chiffrent en deux ans et demi à trente-six millions d'euros, que nous n'avons jamais retrouvés.
Et donc, vous imaginez bien que la corruption, à partir de ce moment-là, elle est impactante, elle est grave et elle se joint à l'autre infraction qui est véritablement le couple infernal de la société aujourd'hui, qui sont les,
je dirais presque les mamelles de la criminalité financière, c'est la corruption et le blanchiment d'argent.
Et vous mettez les deux ensemble, ça, ce sont évidemment les deux cancers de la société aujourd'hui.
Et vous mettez ça en lien alors, une augmentation globale de la criminalité et de la quantité d'argent sale qui circule ?
Quantité d'argent, facilité de la circulation d'argent et paupérisation également.
Tout le monde sait, on a toujours l'image du policier africain corrompu qui va, moyennant un bakchich, laisser la personne tranquille, mais ça parce qu'il n'est pas payé.
Et donc à partir de ce moment-là, quand vous avez une paupérisation, une diminution des moyens, vous avez une augmentation du risque de corruption.
Il y a une organisation internationale qui s'appelle Transparency International, qui est donc chargée de l'évaluation de la corruption dans le monde, pays par pays, qui fait d'ailleurs une espèce de
liste par ordre des pays les plus corrompus au moins corrompus.
Et donc, ils travaillent aussi sur les modus operandi et ils attirent l'attention sur le fait que les pays qui sont en voie de paupérisation sont en voie également de développement, de développement de la corruption. C'est une évidence.
Hum, ça pose de très nombreuses questions. Ça me permet de mettre en avant votre livre : Combattre la criminalité, une urgence démocratique, publié chez Racines, donc il y a quelques mois.
Déjà, première remarque, vous l'avez publié donc en octobre, si je ne dis pas de bêtises, donc il y a vraiment quelques mois, après les élections.
Habituellement, les politiciens publient ça juste avant les élections pour un petit peu faire parler d'eux, pour se faire inviter à gauche, à droite.
Qu'est-ce qui explique ce timing un petit peu étonnant ?
Je vous ai dit que j'étais un mauvais politicien. Moi, je l'ai pas fait pour des motifs politiques. Je l'ai fait en réalité pour des motifs de transmission.
Et je me demande même si le fait de l'avoir fait après les élections ne rend pas plus le texte crédible.
La démarche est plus-
Et d'abord, je tiens à vous signaler une chose, c'est que contrairement aux livres écrits par les politiciens, ce livre-là, c'est moi qui l'ai écrit et pas une plume arme.
Je me suis posé la question.
Donc le mot ne peut plus être utilisé aujourd'hui.
J'ai voulu le vérifier parce qu'effectivement, voilà, donc dans le livre, on peut en parler. Vous explorez la criminalité un petit peu de bout en bout.
Vous parlez de la Cosa Nostra, vous parlez des yakuzas, du djihadisme, de la destruction de l'environnement, la cybercriminalité,
la traite d'êtres humains, la criminalité en col blanc, bien sûr, la financière, la corruption, comme on l'a dit.
Ça fait une grande mosaïque de nombreuses problématiques. Et effectivement, on voit dans les interviews que c'est vraiment des sujets que vous connaissez depuis longtemps et que vous les avez vraiment explorés.
Et ce n'est pas simplement un prêt de plume qui... Ce n'est pas ChatGPT qui a écrit ce livre. Je...
Attention, vous savez que oui, sur un point.
Dites-moi.
Dans la conclusion.
Ah oui, oui, c'est ça.
Je me suis amusé dans la conclusion à interroger ChatGPT parce que j'étais avec un ami en train de déjeuner qui... alors, il me parlait de ChatGPT.
Je lui ai dit : « Tiens, mais je suis en train de conclure mon livre. Comment est-ce que ChatGPT conclurait mon ouvrage sur la criminalité ?
» Alors, on s'amuse. Alors, je dis : « Voilà, je suis l'auteur. Voilà le pitch du bouquin. » Et alors, il me sort un truc, ChatGPT.
Je dis : « Ben c'est tout à fait ça. » Je dis : « Mais si maintenant, je lui pose la question, l'homme politicien un peu mi-voyou, mi-incompétent qui lui poserait la question.
» Il me sort le texte que j'ai repris dans la conclusion. Et pour moi, le summum et la cerise sur le gâteau, c'est évidemment, je dis : « Je suis membre d'une organisation criminelle.
Comment est-ce qu'il conclurait la lecture de mon essai ? » Et il y a ce moment merveilleux : « Mes chers associés, jamais on ne s'est aussi bien portés.
» Alors, je reconnais que, comme ChatGPT, je l'appelle le génie dans la lampe, eh bien, je reconnais que là, nom d'un chien, ça valait la peine que les deux dernières pages, je le cite.
Et quand j'ai dit à mon éditrice : « Ça t'ennuie si je cite ChatGPT ? » Parce que je me suis très fort amusé à le faire.
« Mais ça, c'est formidable, il faut le faire. » Et voilà, c'est comme ça que vous allez lire ces lignes invraisemblables et qui sont en réalité, malheureusement, tout à fait le reflet du livre.
Oui, oui. Hum, donc voilà, on explorait à l'instant donc la question de la paupérisation, la corruption qui s'empire sur ces vingt, trente dernières années.
Si je vous demande de faire une rétrospective sur vos vingt-trois ans d'expérience en tant que juge d'instruction, qu'est-ce que vous avez pu constater comme évolution ?
Et inversement, qu'est-ce qui reste profondément constant dans la criminalité ? Qu'est-ce qui restait pareil ?
Qu'est-ce qui a fort évolué ?
Alors, ce qui a fort évolué, c'est l'accroissement de la délinquance elle-même. Et en même temps, et c'est dramatique, c'est la diminution des moyens pour la combattre.
Ça, les montées, diminutions, ça, c'est une chose que nous avons, nous, les professionnels, de constater. Je suis pas le seul.
Hum, et c'est une chose qui est terrible. Alors l'augmentation, c'est en termes de chiffres. Chaque année, le chiffre, le produit criminel augmente.
Et c'est normal. Parce que finalement, c'est une spirale infernale. Moi, j'avais appelé ça dans le premier essai, dans mon essai sur la criminalité financière, j'avais appelé cela le complexe du brahmane Cisa.
Comme je dis, tout le monde connaît le brahmane Cisa. En général, tout le monde me dit : « Non. » Allez, je vais vous raconter cette histoire.
Vous avez donc dans une Inde légendaire un maharaja qui s'ennuie et le brahmane Cisa, pour l'amuser, lui fait le plus beau cadeau du monde.
Il lui offre le jeu d'échecs. Et le maharaja lui dit : « Je vais te remercier, je t'offre tout ce que tu veux, de l'or, de diamants.
» Et le vieux sage lui dit : « Non, je veux simplement de la nourriture jusqu'à la fin de mes jours. Si tu avais la gentillesse de mettre un grain de riz sur la première case de mon jeu d'échecs, un deuxième grain de riz sur la deuxième,
quatre grains de riz sur la troisième, huit grains de riz sur la quatrième et ainsi de suite jusqu'à la dernière case de mon jeu d'échecs.
» Le maharaja se dit : « Je fais une bonne affaire. » La seule chose qu'il n'avait point prévue, c'est que c'est à ce point exponentiel qu'il faut un millénaire de production de riz pour remplir la dernière case.
Il en est de même avec la criminalité financière. Dans mon nouvel essai, j'ose des chiffres qui sont des chiffres évidemment purement approximatifs, puisque le principe, c'est la clandestinité.
Et je crains malheureusement que les chiffres que je cite, qui sont un croisement d'informations venant des Nations unies, de la Banque mondiale, des instances de l'Union européenne, que je sois en dessous de la réalité.
Mais toutes les criminalités confondues qui rapportent de l'argent, je pense qu'on dépasse largement en Europe les mille milliards d'euros par an.
Mais imaginez-vous que c'est le produit d'une année. Et qui va elle-même s'augmenter l'année d'après par rapport tout simplement à-
L'inflation, les intérêts
L'impunité de ces organisations criminelles qui nous en recentrent à travers le fait de continuer. Mais imaginez-vous aussi que ce produit se mélange aux années précédentes.
Et là, on tombe dans le complexe du brahmane Cisa et que cet argent est blanchi, il rapporte de l'argent et l'année d'avant, et l'année d'avant, et l'année d'avant, etc.
Jusqu'à au combien ?
Sans racine.
C'est foutu. C'est foutu. Et donc là, effectivement, c'est ce que je constate en tout cas dans mon expérience, mes vingt ans d'expérience.
J'ai quand même eu à traiter des très gros dossiers financiers avec des montants qui touchaient parfois des milliards. Eh bien, je peux vous dire que cela s'aggrave,
que ce sentiment d'impunité des criminels vient aussi de ce sentiment d'impunité et aussi de la possibilité, grâce aux techniques et aux conseils dont il dispose, de blanchir avec une facilité dérisoire.
C'est facile de blanchir. Je ne comprends pas que de temps en temps, certains se fassent prendre. Mais en principe, ça ne devrait pas être.
Certains ? Vous pensez à qui ?
Personne.
Une question de chance.
D'adresse.
Ouais ouais. Bien. Donc ça, c'est pour ce que vous avez vu comme évolution en termes vraiment d'importance, en termes du fait que ça se popularise, presque, on a envie de dire ça comme ça.
Inversement, qu'est-ce que vous avez vu comme constance ? Qu'est-ce qui n'a vraiment pas changé ? Qu'est-ce qui est constant, en fait, à travers toutes ces filières de criminalité ?
Non, ce qui n'est pas constant. Dans les filières de criminalité, la constance, c'est leur existence.
Mh.
Alors, il y a deux types de filières criminelles. Il y a les pérennes, comme les grandes mafias siciliennes, chinoises, etc.
Il y a les pérennes autres, comme les associations, comme les macro mafias et autres qui ne sont pas avec, je dirais, des fratries comme il existe en Sicile ou en Chine.
Mais ce sont les mêmes. Ce qui est pérenne, c'est en réalité qu'il ne se passe pas un jour sans que se crée à la seconde une organisation criminelle.
Ce qui est constant, c'est que les moyens dont ils disposent sont utilisés avec une augmentation... C'est peut-être assez marrant de dire que c'est constant, mais c'est en augmentation.
Par exemple, les moyens informatiques. Les organisations criminelles disposent de plus en plus de moyens informatiques et nous sommes toujours avec dix guerres de retard.
Mh.
Si pas vingt guerres de retard, si pas trente guerres. Nous sommes passés en matière de justice-
La constance, c'est l'inflexibilité.
Ben oui.
Voilà.
Exactement. Et donc ce qui est quand même extraordinaire en matière de justice, j'avais cité ça dans une de mes conférences.
En matière de justice, nous sommes passés du Moyen Âge à la Préhistoire. Et quelqu'un me dit : « Vous voulez dire qu'on est passé de la Préhistoire au Moyen Âge ?
» Je dis : « Non, on est passé du Moyen Âge à la Préhistoire
». Ah, c'est un petit peu le drame. Nous sommes tout à fait d'une incompétence totale à attribuer les moyens nécessaires face à l'immensité de ces phénomènes, à nous attribuer, à nous, les professionnels sensibles
et connaissant véritablement les implications que cela peut avoir en termes de démocratie.
Il n'y a personne qui va nous donner les moyens suffisants que pour lutter convenablement contre cette augmentation. Et la constance dans tout cela, c'est que ça ne risque pas de disparaître.
Mh. C'est pas du tout avance alors.
Oui, d'une certaine manière, mais on peut peut-être limiter les dégâts à défaut de faire marche arrière.
Oui oui. Mais ça demande-
En tout cas, arrêter les comportements.
Oui. Ça demande des moyens.
Ah énormément, oui.
On a eu l'occasion d'en discuter.
Assez défairement, je dois dire,
quand j'ai fait mon interview de Thierry Marchandise il y a deux mois,
où, voilà, on faisait le constat des prisons sous-staffées, des magistrats en dépression, des affaires qui prennent du retard deux ans, trois ans et puis qui finalement dépassent le nombre maximal.
Voilà. Alors, vous vous êtes maintenant passé dans le monde politique.
Mais non.
Écoutez, vous avez un siège au conseil communal de Forest. Alors, c'est loin-
C'est pas là que je vais combattre le blanchiment. À moins peut-être que je détecte une corruption au sein du conseil communal.
Je plaisante, il n'y a pas de raison.
Si vous avez un scoop pour moi, n'hésitez pas. Mais... Mais oui, effectivement, c'est vrai que ça m'a un petit peu étonné.
C'est-à-dire que là où dans les interviews, vous avez beaucoup tendance à parler des questions judiciaires, des questions de criminalité, etc, puisque c'est, voilà, votre expérience.
Voilà, on voit quand même relativement peu le rapport avec le siège communal à Forest, je dois dire.
Ah, vous vous trompez encore.
C'est vous qui venez de le dire.
Non, parce qu'en réalité, grâce à cela, ça m'a permis d'être élu au conseil de police.
Ah oui, d'accord.
C'est tout dit. Voilà. Et en même temps, je peux participer maintenant, ça, ça va se décider ce soir, je verrai. Je participerai à des commissions en matière de culture.
Parce que mon autre casquette, c'est évidemment, et vous le savez, c'est la culture.
Ouais.
Et donc, en réalité, d'une certaine manière, j'ai peut-être pas été... enfin, j'ai pas été élu au fédéral, mais en tant que mandat politique, j'ai un peu ce que je veux, là.
Je suis extrêmement content. Et alors, je peux vous dire une chose, j'ai mon deuxième conseil communal ce soir, quand nous parlons.
Je l'attends parce que moi, j'aime bien, vraiment. Et j'aime bien être en contact avec la vie sociale et voir ce qu'on peut faire de mieux.
Quand on est dans l'opposition, ça ne consiste pas nécessairement à dire : « Je ne suis pas d'accord ». C'est vraiment réfléchir ensemble vers un mieux.
Et de temps en temps, dire : « Je ne suis pas d'accord », parce qu'il y a des questions de principe de l'autre côté avec lesquelles on ne peut pas s'accorder.
Oui. Donc voilà, je reviens sur ce que je disais à l'instant, la question des manques de moyens, la question de la...
voilà, des magistrats qui tombent tous en dépression, apparemment, et qui-
Ah non, moi, je ne tombe pas en dépression.
Peut-être que c'est différent quand juge d'instruction, mais en tout cas, les avocats, les procureurs, les juges, etc.
Voient la question des moyens, la question de-
Ah ça, oui, c'est épouvantable.
C'est très difficile de-
Écoutez, il y a une étude de Justice qui dit qu'il manque 43 % de magistrats. Alors, comment voulez-vous qu'on fonctionne ?
Alors, donc ça, c'est largement dû aux questions budgétaires, puisqu'il y a eu une diminution des moyens, notamment en 2014 sous le gouvernement Michel I.
Risque-t-il d'y avoir sans doute ? Alors, ça dépend qui on écoute, puisque on est dans un contexte d'austérité, des coupes budgétaires.
D'après les dernières fuites, on ne sait pas si on peut tout à fait s'y fier, mais d'après les fuites des négociations qui sont en cours actuellement pour le fédéral, semblerait que les moyens soient plutôt en augmentation pour la justice.
Euh donc euh-
On n'a pas les mêmes fuites alors.
Ah on n'a pas... Ah OK, vous avez des fu... Vous... D'après ce que vous avez entendu, on continue dans la, dans-
Je pense que d'après ce que j'ai entendu, j'aurais du travail.
Du travail quoi ? Au niveau-
Analyser le, le... Pour autant que l'Arizona connaisse le jour, mais parce que c'est pas encore tout à fait fait.
Oui, non, c'est sûr.
Je pense que j'aurais du boulot à analyser le,
les centaines de pages qui sont en train de nous concocter pour voir véritablement si cela est cohérent avec l'approche de la société actuelle qui nécessite d'avoir une justice convenable.
Je dis même pas plus forte, je dis tout simplement existante et convenable. On verra. Mais d'après ce que j'entends, c'est mal barré.
Voilà, OK. Mais donc, si on part de cette idée-là, que ce sera vraisemblablement mal barré, qu'est-ce qui explique ce décalage entre
donc la population qui désire, voilà, notamment dans le contexte des fusillades ici à Forest, ici à Bruxelles,
dans le contexte de trafic de drogue, désire plus de sécurité, qui est globalement insatisfait des questions judiciaires qui prennent des années à être réglées.
Tous les témoignages qui concernent les prisons, les magistrats que j'ai déjà évoqués. Donc la population est demandeuse d'une amélioration vis-à-vis de ces questions.
Les politiciens qui ont gagné, voilà, le mouvement Informateur pour le Palais de Mai, voilà, dans son programme, met très fort en avant les questions sécuritaires, etc.
Qu'est-ce qui explique alors ce décalage dans le concret, finalement ?
Oui. Mais il faut pas confondre l'effet d'annonce avec l'annonce d'un effet hein. Il y a la création, évoquée par Gelbé, comme on l'appelle, d'un ministère.
Non, c'est la N-VA qui l'avait fait. D'un ministère de la Sécurité. Mais à quoi ça sert ? À partir du moment où il existe déjà l'Intérieur et la Justice, il suffit tout simplement d'accorder un ministère de la Sécurité.
Moi, je trouve ça d'ailleurs, c'est un bruit de bottes comme ça qui me dérange profondément. Je n'aime pas du tout.
1984 un petit peu.
C'est ça, il y a de ça, j'aime pas du tout. Alors qu'on a toutes les possibilités structurelles d'agir. Non, mais non, soyons clairs.
Le problème de la justice ne se limite pas à la sécurité. La sécurité, on se tire dessus dans les rues, on s'est mis ici à Forest, ici à l'altitude cent, il y a un type qui a vidé un chargeur de Kalachnikov.
Vous imaginez ça à l'altitude cent dans le haut de Forest. Et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans le bas, à la place Saint-Antoine ?
Et je limite ça à la commune dans laquelle nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui. Le problème de la sécurité, c'est que le citoyen, c'est un droit.
Le droit à la sécurité, c'est quelque chose de totalement inaliénable et ça fait partie du droit démocratique. Actuellement, on peut véritablement dire que nous connaissons une dégradation de ce droit.
Il y a des pays où c'est beaucoup plus grave hein. Mais quand même, moi, ce qui m'inquiète, c'est que la dégradation, elle est en cours.
Les phénomènes qui sont au départ de cette dégradation, c'est un : la paupérisation.
Deux : c'est l'augmentation de la puissance des organisations criminelles, parce que ceux qui tirent dans les rues, ce sont leurs tout petits soldats, mais les organisations criminelles sont de plus en plus puissantes.
Et troisièmement, c'est l'impunité dont elles se sont revêtues. Mettez les trois ensemble, ça ne va pas reculer, ça ne peut qu'augmenter.
Alors, lutter contre la sécurité, il y en a qui disent : « Mais voilà, le ministre de la Sécurité, on va mettre plus de...
» On appelle ça les Bleus dans les rues. C'est pas le MR hein. Les Bleus, c'est les policiers, voilà. On va avoir plus de Bleus dans les rues.
Oui, parce qu'aujourd'hui, si on prend le cas de Forest, par exemple, bah quand on appelle quelqu'un la nuit pour un problème, ben la patrouille vient d'Anderlecht, doit franchir toute une série de cordons, ça prend un temps de dingue.
On aura bientôt, à deux pas d'ici, un nouveau commissariat qui va se créer tout près.
Ça, c'est une avancée, évidemment, mais il existe quand même aussi des mesures qui doivent être prises, et notamment en termes de Good Move, pour que les policiers puissent intervenir plus rapidement et les pompiers.
Hein, c'est le même problème. Et donc ça, nous le connaissons actuellement en termes de communes et Forest n'est pas la seule commune impactée à cet égard.
On a un véritable manque en termes de sécurité, d'un besoin d'intervention de la police zonale. Mais j'y reviens. J'y reviens.
Le problème de sécurité dans les rues, c'est comme quelqu'un qui a mal aux dents. Quand vous avez mal aux dents, vous allez prendre un Dafalgan.
Ça, c'est mettre les policiers dans les rues. Vous aurez moins mal aux dents. Mais l'abcès est toujours là.
Voilà, on règle le problème de surface, mais pas en profondeur.
Vous devez arracher la dent malade. Et ça, c'est le fédéral. Le fédéral est encore plus laminé que la police zonale, en tout cas dans certaines communes.
Ce sont les comm... Vous avez déjà remarqué que ce sont les communes les plus riches où il y a le moins de délinquance. Vous avez une explication là-dessus, hein ?
Je plaisante. Mais donc là, pour moi, le problème, il est évidemment au-dessus par rapport à la lutte contre les organisations criminelles.
Et lutter contre les organisations criminelles, et j'en reviens à mon message perpétuel, c'est non seulement une lutte qui doit se faire au niveau des
policiers qui luttent contre les narcotrafiquants, par exemple, pour prendre cette infraction-là.
Il y a le trafic d'armes, le trafic d'êtres humains, etc. Mais c'est d'une manière globale chercher l'argent, follow the money.
C'est là qu'on doit les tenir et chercher leurs conseillers. Vous vous souvenez de ce film avec Tom Cruise, de cet excellent livre de Grisham qui s'appelle The Firm ?
Ouais, j'allais citer un autre film, mais non, dites-moi.
Ah ben, c'est magnifique hein. Donc, vous avez le jeune avocat qui est engagé dans une société d'avocats qui traite le blanchiment d'argent de la mafia.
Et alors, le FBI tente de le coincer parce que le frère de l'avocat est en taule, il tente de le... bla bla. Et donc, il lui exerce un chantage terrible.
Il doit fournir des renseignements concernant le blanchiment d'argent des mafias fait par ses patrons et par lui, bien indirectement.
Et à un certain moment, il dit non. Par contre, il fournit au FBI une série d'informations qui rendent les policiers du FBI fous furieux.
En réalité, il y a rien sur les éléments du blanchiment parce que Tom Cruise, qui joue le rôle de l'avocat, leur dit : « Moi, je suis avocat.
Jamais vous n'aurez l'information concernant mes clients. J'ai prêté serment. C'est le secret professionnel absolu. Par contre, voilà, je vous donne ici tous les time sheets faux de l'association d'avocats.
Ils ont falsifié leur time sheet pour demander plus d'honoraires. » Ça, le FBI dit : « À quoi ça sert ? » C'est un crime fédéral puni jusqu'à vingt ans de prison.
Et là, vous les aurez.
Une félonie.
Et donc, en réalité... Et il termine par cela en disant : « Si vous voulez tuer les mafias, commencez par arrêter leurs avocats.
» Traduisez leurs blanchisseurs et tous ceux qui, dans les professionnels du chiffre, pratiquent cela. C'est ça qu'il faut faire.
Avec cela, on a une chance réelle de tenter d'éviter qu'on se tire encore dessus dans les rues un certain moment.
C'est intéressant parce que moi, j'allais citer une autre, une série qui s'appelle The Wire, qui est donc écrite et réalisée par David Simon, qui était anciennement journaliste.
Donc The Wire pour dire sur écoute.
Sur écoute, oui.
Voilà, on met sur écoute les lignes téléphoniques. Ça se passe au début des années 2000 avec les cabines téléphoniques et puis l'arrivée des téléphones portables et tout ça.
Il y a une citation qui m'a marqué dans cette série, c'était un policier qui explique que si on suit les dealers de drogue, on va trouver plus de drogue.
Mais à partir du moment où on commence à suivre l'argent, on ne sait pas sur qui on va arriver. Et concrètement, dans la série, ils tombent sur des politiciens et ils commencent à avoir des problèmes à ce moment-là.
Et leur enquête commence à avoir des sérieux problèmes. Et donc là, on rejoint la question de la corruption, finalement.
C'est si on suit l'argent, est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas rapidement à les se faire...
La corruption, elle est à tous les niveaux hein, comme vous avez au sommet de l'État jusqu'au plus bas. Mais je ne pense pas, par exemple, à des...
Quand je dis à des parlementaires, il y a quand même eu des grands scandales qui se sont faits, que nous avons rencontrés.
Non, je pense vraiment qu'elle existe. Je ne pense pas que la Belgique puisse être qualifiée d'État corrompu ni de narco-État.
On vous pose tout le temps la question.
Parce que c'est un petit peu, c'est un peu exagéré.
Dans toutes les interviews, on me demande si la Belgique est un narco-État.
Vous avez vu ce que j'ai écrit dans mon bouquin ? Ma réponse, elle est simple.
Oui, c'est clair.
Mais non. Quoique.
Oui, c'est ça.
Et c'est le quoique qui est embêtant. Parce que,
à considérer que en blanchiment, on est quand même au sommet, en corruption, ben,
il y a dans l'affaire Sky ECC, qui est ce célèbre procès dans lequel on a mis en évidence, parce que pour une fois, c'est la police qui a hacké les truands et pas l'inverse.
Donc on a arrêté cent trente personnes et vous avez dix policiers qui vont faire l'objet de poursuites, corrompus.
Donc la corruption est là. Et donc, je vous parle de ces fonctionnaires que j'ai arrêtés dans une commune de l'agglomération bruxelloise.
Mais donc la corruption est à toutes les strates. Le blanchiment, il est là. D'un autre côté, la violence s'exprime dans les rues.
On connaît les montants. On sait sur écoute téléphonique que un, le port d'Anvers est
obstrué par les containers bourrés de cocaïne qui arrivent un peu partout, que un gramme de cocaïne se vend cinquante euros et qu'on peut quand même compter entre neuf cent tonnes et mille tonnes par an qui passent à travers.
Dites, faites un peu le calcul, c'est beaucoup hein. Vous ajoutez à ça Amsterdam, Rotterdam, Brest, le Pirée, Marseille, etc.
C'est vraiment beaucoup beaucoup, sans compter les autres moyens de transport et que nous avons donc la Belgique qui est une plaque centrale de plusieurs trafics, dont le narcotrafic.
Que nous avons aussi des éléments extérieurs, comme le fait qu'on tente d'enlever notre ancien ministre de la Justice, monsieur Van Quickenborne.
Nous avons quand même la fameuse corruption des policiers. Aux Pays-Bas, vous avez des personnes assassinées, magistrats et journalistes.
Pardon, excusez-moi, avocats et journalistes. Vous avez la famille royale menacée aux Pays-Bas. La Mocro Mafia oblige des gens à quitter des quartiers entiers d'Amsterdam.
Pays-Bas, c'est la Belgique hein, c'est... Alors que nous avons chez nous une perte de contrôle totale en termes de deal.
Nous sommes en train de parler, vous et moi. Si vous voulez un petit joint, moi, je vous amène. Dans dix mètres, je vous en trouve un.
C'est pas... On va au parking du grand magasin de chez vous, ils sont déjà là. Et donc, tout ça est d'une grande hypocrisie également, que les policiers assistent au deal sans intervenir, parce qu'ils en ont pas envie ou pas les moyens.
On ne sait pas leur en vouloir. Que voulez que ils fassent
? Alors, je me demande si nous ne sommes pas face à une question que je mets dans mon bouquin comme telle, parce que je le pense profondément, que la vraie question, si ça continue et qu'on ne fait rien,
ce n'est pas de savoir si la Belgique est devenue
un narco-État, mais c'est de savoir quand elle le deviendra.
Ça, c'est la vraie question.
Elle va dans cette direction, même si c'est à un rythme très lent. Malgré tout, les choses s'empirent. J'avais pas prévu de poser cette question, mais puisque vous parlez de trafic de joints dans le quartier, est-ce que...
La réponse est oui.
Oui.
Je suis pour la libéralisation du cannabis.
C'est ça que vous avez demandé ? Tout à fait.
Ah oui, j'ai quand même encore un peu le...
Je suis un garçon très prévisible, apparemment. Mais voilà.
J'ai pas dit que vous sentiez la beuh.
J'espère bien. Donc le... C'est, voilà. Vous estimez que ce serait un moyen intéressant pour faire baisser les questions de criminalité ?
Écoutez, ça fait quinze ans que je l'écris, donc c'est pas du tout une surprise hein, bien avant d'avoir un programme politique ou quoi que ce soit.
C'est l'évidence et nous sommes ô combien nombreux à le penser. C'est une telle hypocrisie parce qu'il y a des pays limitrophes un peu plus loin en Europe où la vente est libre, organisée.
Regardez un petit peu ce que ça rapporte au Colorado, ils ne savaient plus quoi faire de leur bénéfice économique sur la vente du cannabis.
Mais c'est l'hypocrisie générale d'une part, mais c'est surtout le fait que les produits actuels qui sont vendus, c'est vraiment des produits coupés qui sont dangereux pour la santé publique,
que d'autre part, ça engraisse les organisations criminelles, bien sûr.
Alors, pour moi, et je parle d'une expérience du cannabis pour commencer, je pense qu'il serait vraiment fondamental pour la société de libéraliser cette crasse en organisant la vente.
Mh.
Et donc, à partir de ce moment-là, vous pourriez avoir un bénéfice qui vous permettrait de venir en aide sociale. Moi, l'aide sociale est fondamentale, plus que la répression dans le cadre des consommateurs,
et des petits dealers qui sont consommateurs.
Moi, je suis pour des interventions sociales et non pas de répression. À partir de ce moment-là, on aurait des montants qui permettraient justement d'avoir cette aide sociale, de,
bien entendu, profiter à l'État, de libérer les forces de police qui travaillent.
Oh, je plains déjà les petits fournisseurs de Matongé à Ixelles qui vivent de ça. J'en suis désolé,
mais d'un autre côté, ça permettrait à la police de travailler sur d'autres dossiers plus importants et de tenter de régler le problème des seringues qu'on trouve dans le parc de Saint-Gilles ou dans le parc de Forest,
plutôt que de continuer à poursuivre finalement la chose qui est devenue vraiment
le plaisir du vendredi soir pour une certaine jeunesse.
Et voilà, c'est comme ça, c'est un phénomène de société. Moi, je... Vous savez, l'excès d'alcool c'est pas bon hein.
Les toxicomanies ne sont pas bonnes en général. L'excès du jeu, c'est la même chose. Eh bien, c'est la même chose avec l'excès de joints.
Et alors quand on me dit : « Oui, mais enfin, il va fumer, puis vous allez libéraliser, il va passer à la coke. » Est-ce que vous pouvez me prouver que celui qui a fumé un joint, qui pourra l'acheter avec une bonne qualité, va passer à la coke ?
Vous savez, il a pas besoin que ce soit libéralisé pour passer à la coke s'il a en lui le problème pathologique de l'addiction hein.
Bon, franchement, non. Et au contraire, je pense que ce serait un moyen de combattre plus efficacement alors le trafic de cocaïne.
Ça me permet de faire un lien avec donc la question de Sky ECC que vous évoquiez il y a un instant. C'est
sans doute une des plus grandes évolutions depuis ces vingt, trente dernières années,
c'est le chiffrement des messages, le fait que les criminels peuvent communiquer, les crim... les criminels et les citoyens de manière générale peuvent communiquer de façon
voilà, chiffrée, sécurisée assez facilement.
Et concrètement, si on va demander maintenant à,
pour prendre cet exemple-là, à Apple de donner les messages qui ont été échangés entre deux iPhone via l'application Message, ils vont dire : « Bah en fait non, moi, je n'ai pas les clés pour savoir ça.
C'est seulement les utilisateurs qui ont leur code secret, leur empreinte digitale qui permet de déchiffrer tout ça.
Moi, je ne sais pas. » Et du coup, on ne peut demander à personne. Dans le cas de Sky ECC, il y avait une faille, mais idéalement,
dans le cas d'un chiffrement de bout en bout, on peut demander à personne, à part les deux personnes qui échangent des messages.
Ça pose des sérieux problèmes, évidemment, pour les forces de l'ordre, à nouveau, qui souhaiteraient avancer dans l'enquête.
Et en même temps, on revient à la question qu'on évoquait un peu plus tôt, le droit à la vie privée, le fait que,
voilà, c'est finalement assez légitime dans un contexte liberticide, dans un contexte de surveillance de masse, de vouloir chiffrer ses communications, voilà, dans certains contextes.
Bah, pour le deuxième volet de votre question, mettre les choses en balance, moi, vous savez, je préfère prendre un très léger risque en matière de vie privée parce que je sais que les structures sont là pour la protéger.
Pour l'instant.
Plutôt que de... Oui, mais je... pour l'instant. Et ça, on peut encore faire marche arrière après. Par contre, le... je parle d'enquête immédiate hein, pas de banque de données.
Je vous parle véritablement d'enquête immédiate.
Voilà, c'est immédiat.
Et je crois qu'il est plus important pour l'instant de foutre par terre les organisations criminelles qui sont en train tout simplement de nous amener vers d'autres règles encore plus liberticides de par le pouvoir qu'ils vont occuper.
Voilà, votre première partie. Tout est une question de technique.
Oui, je réagirai déjà à ça sur le fait que les fuites d'Edward Snowden sont sorties il y a plus de dix ans.
Oui.
Et on voit que là, ce n'est absolument pas opéré dans un cadre judiciaire.
Non.
Et illicite.
C'est ainsi.
Pour ma part, je pense que les organisations criminelles sont beaucoup plus dangereuses actuellement que peut-être certaines exploitations de données de vie privée obtenues illégalement, je dis bien illégalement,
par rapport à une faille de la protection de la vie privée qui aurait peut-être pour origine à un certain moment une origine policière ou judiciaire.
Je pense que c'est une infime exception, mais c'est un peu le problème de Pegasus, par exemple. Donc vous savez que c'est un programme que je pense-
Israélien, ouais.
Problème israélien. La Belgique a acheté ce programme, je peux pas m'imaginer que l'on ne l'ait pas.
Mais le problème, c'est que ce programme a été diffusé évidemment dans des tas d'autres organisations, dont des criminelles, on le sait.
Alors qu'au départ, Israël avait bien dit : « Jamais nous ne fournirons ça à d'autres », mais que voulez-vous, ça se reproduit.
Alors, tout est une question de technique. Tout est une question de moyens pour faire évoluer la technique. Il y a des pays qui sont des hyper spécialistes en matière de technique.
La Russie, bah ça, je ne suis pas sûr qu'on doit attendre grand-chose d'eux. Israël, quand même, est pas mal développé. Les États-Unis.
Et là, il faut véritablement, à mon avis, pouvoir travailler chez nous, développer les capacités scientifiques, pour augmenter la possibilité d'accéder aux données criminelles comme on a fait avec Sky ECC. Je résume Sky ECC.
N'oubliez pas la Chine.
Nous connaissions... Bah, c'est les pires de tous. Mais le,
quand vous arrivez en Chine, par exemple, nous, les professionnels, quand on était amenés à voyager en Chine, on devait laisser nos ordinateurs et nos GSM à Bruxelles et on recevait un GSM vide qui servait uniquement parce que le simple fait
de franchir la frontière, on était déjà complètement hackés dans nos informations contenues dans le GSM.
Et donc ça, c'est un peu les Chinois quoi, ils sont curieux. Ah, qu'est-ce qu'ils sont curieux. Mais ils ont tout.
Je sais pas si vous imaginez mais-
C'est un bel euphémisme.
Les Chinois pourraient nous couper d'énergie assez facilement, avec les panneaux solaires. 80 % des panneaux solaires sont livrés par la Chine.
Quand vous réglez vos panneaux solaires, c'est avec le...
Oui, des téléphones Huawei, etc.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Des antennes 5G Huawei, etc.
Eh bien, ils ont accès à tout, donc ils pourraient tout bloquer. C'est extrêmement simple. Il faut arriver, alors, pour un petit peu, j'allais dire, rassurer ceux qui pourraient penser que la vie privée est en danger par rapport à cela.
Dans un cas comme Sky ECC, c'était bien limité aux criminels. Donc ce sont des criminels qui ont été visés dans cette enquête, il n'y avait pas d'autres personnes pour des motifs, par exemple, politiques.
Dans la vente de Pegasus, Israël avait bien dit : « Jamais on ne touchera à des personnes qui pourraient utiliser pour des motifs politiques
le système Pegasus », qui a donc été utilisé dans certains pays du Moyen-Orient pour lutter contre les opposants politiques.
Parce qu'évidemment, vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez, mais ça, vous allez passer à travers. Donc là, soyons clairs, je suis d'accord pour les garde-fous et tout le monde est d'accord, ça va de soi.
Mais je suis aussi d'accord, ça, je vous ai parlé d'audace tout à l'heure dans les enquêtes. Si on ne fait pas preuve d'un peu d'audace de temps en temps, mais dans le respect de la vie privée, à partir de ce moment-là, bah,
vous mettez alors en évidence le fait que,
écoutez, l'organisation criminelle est là, mais on pourrait peut-être avoir une donnée qui concerne quelqu'un qui n'en fait pas partie et faisons marche arrière.
Et ça, je ne veux pas.
Mh.
Je vais revenir sur la question des moyens qu'on octroie à la justice, ces questions de budget, puisque encore une fois, on est dans un contexte
d'austérité où on essaie de faire des coupes, voilà, sur la plupart des services publics.
Inversement, ce qu'on entend régulièrement, c'est qu'il y aurait énormément de patrimoine au niveau de la fraude fiscale, au niveau du un pour cent, des très très très très riches en Belgique. Hum,
est-ce qu'il y a une volonté au niveau des pouvoirs publics, au niveau des élus,
de s'attaquer à ces assets-là ? J'ai été, je crois, à jamais marqué par, je crois qu'il travaillait avec vous, Jean-Luc Crucke, lorsqu'il était encore au Mouvement réformateur,
avait refusé de voter une loi qui visait à courir après, justement, les personnes qui faisaient de la fraude fiscale.
Donc le-- Pardon, non, c'est l'inverse. Lui était en faveur de cette loi et monsieur Gelb, justement, estimait que ça visait un peu trop leur électorat.
Bon, voilà, c'était une formule intéressante. Hum, est-ce que-- Donc voilà, je sens que ça m'a marqué.
C'est vrai, vous avez raison.
Est-ce que vous estimez qu'il y a aujourd'hui, au sein de la Chambre des représentants, au sein de nos élus,
une volonté suffisante pour courir après ce patrimoine-là, le patrimoine de la fraude fiscale ?
On parle bien du patrimoine de la fraude fiscale, parce qu'il y a des tas de gens que j'avais rencontrés en cours de campagne qui confondaient un petit peu le fait d'être riche et le fait d'être un fraudeur.
L'un ne veut pas nécessairement dire l'autre. Alors soyons clairs, on parle des fraudeurs.
Pas selon Gelb, mais oui, OK.
Il est, comment dire, un peu particulier. La fraude fiscale, c'est une infraction pénale. Qu'elle soit grave ou organisée, ou même la fraude fiscale simple, ce sont des infractions pénales.
Donc, en réalité, ça représente combien de produits non déclarés. Mais je vous parle des gens honnêtes, hein, donc je vous parle pas des narcotrafiquants et autres.
Ceux qui ont une activité normale et qui ne déclarent pas, c'est plus ou moins trente milliards par an en Belgique.
Vous appelez les gens honnêtes.
Donc ça fait six à sept pour cent du PIB brut belge. Donc les gens honnêtes, c'est le, bah, c'est le coiffeur, c'est l'entrepreneur, c'est les sociétés de nettoyage, etc.
Sauf que là, évidemment, le problème, c'est que, en général, la fraude fiscale s'accompagne de tas d'autres infractions comme le faux et usage de faux, la falsification de bilan, etc.
Donc ça, ça va déjà de manière un peu plus grave que le fait que vous allez au restaurant et qu'on ne vous donne pas la note TVA.
On en est loin, mais la fraude fiscale, ça reste quand même effectivement un problème. Alors, sur le plan strictement de la répression fiscale, ben écoutez, le SPF Finances est désossé quoi.
Il faut quand même se reconnaître que la gestion du SPF Finances n'a pas été top ces dernières années en termes de structurels.
Vous avez, en plus de ça, moi, j'ose le mot, hein, donc vous savez, je m'avance. Je parlerai même dans la communication de véritable escroquerie intellectuelle,
dans la mesure où les montants qui sont avancés en termes de résultats ne sont pas les montants qui ont été récupérés par l'administration fiscale, mais qui ont été enrôlés, donc, c'est-à-dire des créances.
Qu'une créance ne savait rien faire quand vous avez dans ces créances des sociétés qui vont tomber en faillite, qui sont des coquilles vides.
Or, le plus grand des montants annoncés comme des résultats sont en réalité des créances et pas des sous qui sont tombés dans, cling, le pot de l'État.
Alors, trente milliards. Mais imaginez-vous que vous arrivez donc à douze, treize milliards d'impôts. Vous imaginez, en termes de budget, ça change tout, hein, par rapport au fonctionnement de l'État.
Vous feriez fonctionner les valeurs de la démocratie sociale de manière plus juste, comme la justice, la culture, l'enseignement, les soins de santé et la solidarité, si on avait ne fût-ce que ce montant-là.
Alors, je vous passe évidemment la totalité des autres infractions qui sont déjà bien plus graves que la simple fraude fiscale, et sociale.
Il faut démêler les deux, c'est, ils sont,
indissociables. La fraude sociale a d'ailleurs pris véritablement un pas extrêmement important dans notre société belge et les autres infractions comme les narcotrafiquants, etc.
C'est de la fraude fiscale aussi, mais bon, l'infraction en amont, c'est quand même autre chose que la simple non-déclaration dans sa déclaration.
Voilà. Donc, le-- Mais rien que ça, c'est déjà grave. Alors écoutez, est-ce que quand vous dites : « Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, on peut dire que on prend pas...
» Ça a toujours été-
Est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de la part des élus ?
Écoutez, la volonté de la part des élus, c'est quasiment les considérer comme étant les complices. J'ai presque envie de dire oui, d'une certaine manière, parce que je peux pas croire qu'ils ne soient pas informés.
Et ça fait quand même des années que nous sommes plusieurs professionnels à vouloir les informer de l'immensité du phénomène.
Il y a un manque de volonté de la part des élus.
Oui, bien sûr. Mais il a toujours existé. Mais pas des élus d'aujourd'hui. C'est le mot aujourd'hui que je voudrais enlever dans votre question en disant : « Ça a toujours été le cas.
» Je prends un exemple de petit sursaut, où on a tenté de faire quelque chose : Di Rupo.
Gouvernement Di Rupo, vous avez un secrétariat d'État à la lutte contre la fraude fiscale et sociale, John Crombez, qui est aujourd'hui le bourgmestre d'Ostende, à Vooruit, à l'époque, c'était le SP.
Il avait, comme secrétaire d'État, pris les choses en main. Et il avait un ennemi au sein du gouvernement qui lui mettait des bâtons dans les roues.
C'était le ministre des Finances qui lui disait : « Mais enfin, John, tu touches à notre zone de confort. »
Est-ce que ce serait pas Didier Reynders à l'époque ? Non, c'était qui ?
Je le dirai dans un instant. Et John avait véritablement, j'ai travaillé avec lui aussi hein, donc avait véritablement pris les choses en main.
Et là, il y a vraiment eu une avancée. Et puis, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Fin du gouvernement Di Rupo, arrive la Suédoise.
Et là, on va scinder. Louis Michel va pas du tout faire une, je dirais, émettre un intérêt à l'égard de la lutte contre la criminalité financière.
Et le secrétariat d'État va être scindé en deux : fraude fiscale d'un côté et fraude sociale de l'autre. À la fraude fiscale, on met une gynécologue.
Il a fallu six mois d'existence, puis c'était terminé parce qu'elle n'y connaissait rien. Et puis, à la fraude sociale, ah bon, une droite flamande qui dit : « Et vous allez voir les chômeurs, ça va pas se passer comme ça.
» La fraude sociale, c'est pas ça. La fraude sociale, c'est les patrons, c'est pas les chômeurs. C'est pas bien d'être chômeur et de travailler en noir,
mais le petit montant que ça représente n'est rien par rapport au brassage des affaires en matière de fraude sociale des patrons.
Déjà, pas mal. Et on vient à la Vivaldi. Imaginez dans ma position, la Vivaldi, il y a les socialistes et il y a les écolos quoi.
Je plonge sur le programme, rien par rapport à la lutte contre la communauté financière et en plus la suppression pure et simple des deux secrétariats d'État.
Alors, si vous pensez que ça, c'est pas la volonté tout simplement de ne pas agir dans ce système, qui était le premier ministre de la Vivaldi ?
Alexander De Croo.
Ministre des Finances à l'époque.
Ah bah voilà.
De Roupo.
Premier invité de ce podcast.
Vous voyez un petit peu-
Je ne lui ai pas posé la question, c'est vrai.
Alors, je me suis bien amusé avec Alexander De Croo parce que cet homme a incontestablement des compétences.
Je le trouve brillant et sympathique, mais il y a un jour quand même, il a dit une grosse bêtise.
Et je pense qu'il est dans son néolibéralisme un peu en dehors des préoccupations que je développe parce qu'il n'a jamais rencontré véritablement sur le plan factuel les problèmes que nous connaissons.
J'adorerais cette émission. Chez Pascal Vrebos. Donc, il passe, alors c'était il y a six, sept ans, six ans.
Sur RTL, alors.
Et alors, j'avais gueulé avec Frédéric Van Leeuw à l'époque, qui était procureur fédéral, et avec Ignacio de La Serna, qui était le procureur général de Mons.
On avait hurlé en disant : « Narcotrafiquants, les mafias sont en train de prendre le pouvoir. Si ça continue comme ça, on va se tirer dessus dans les rues quoi.
Et la Belgique est corrompue dans ce système. » Et là-dessus, Pascal Vrebos, je connais juste clair, s'est énervé dans la Libre hier : « La Belgique est un État corrompu.
» Ce que j'ai jamais dit. J'ai dit que la corruption existait à tous les étages. Là, sur Alexander De Croo : « Quoi ? Mais ça, il peut pas dire hein.
Et d'ailleurs, qu'il le prouve. » Alors là, tous les professionnels ont dit : « Mais attends, il délire ou quoi ? » Et quelques années plus tard, il y a Pascal Vrebos qui me téléphone en disant : « Tiens, il y a Alexander De Croo qui revient.
T'as quelque chose à lui dire ? » Je lui dis : « Tu repasses en boucle son "qu'il le prouve" et tu passes en boucle Sky ECC, le Qatar Gate, les infractions dans les communes, les policiers arrêtés, etc.
» Et tu dis : « Vous pensez pas que c'est prouvé aujourd'hui ? Pour autant que ce soit nécessaire à l'époque de le faire.
» Il le fait et Alexander De Croo lui dit : « Oui, il faudra faire quelque chose. » Alors, je l'aime bien, mais là, je pense que la première fois, il aurait mieux valu qu'il se taise.
J'essaierai de retrouver cet extrait, c'est fameux ce que vous décrivez. Le, l'autre exemple que j'ai en tête, c'est vis-à-vis de son néolibéralisme, c'est qu'il était très--
avant tous les francophones, il était fortement en faveur de,
du fait d'arrêter les allocations de chômage après deux ans.
Bah ça revient hein.
Et oui, voilà. Maintenant, c'est du côté francophone qu'on en parle beaucoup maintenant. Et il y avait aussi le fait que pendant le Covid, il était assez méprisant avec les personnes qui voulaient,
qui-- enfin, il y avait un-- auprès d'une certaine population,
une absence totale de dialogue avec les autorités publiques.
Et donc quand on disait aux gens : « Allez vous faire vacciner », il y avait presque automatiquement chez ces populations-là une méfiance et pas envie de faire ce que les autorités nous disent.
Et il y avait une stigmatisation assez importante de la part de Alexander De Croo, qui parlait de ces gens-là comme étant des idiots quoi.
Mais enfin bon, c'est...
Mais moi, j'étais vacciné, donc je peux d'autant plus facilement prendre la parole-
Je me suis vacciné avant tout le monde, moi-même.
Je trouve que le droit, à toute personne de ne pas vouloir se faire vacciner en subissant les conséquences administratives que ça entraînait.
Mais c'est un droit. Je ne vois pas pourquoi on mépriserait ces personnes.
C'est-- disons que dans le cadre d'une pandémie, il y avait des réflexions qui allaient au-delà d'une personne-
Oui, mais enfin, la vaccination n'empêche pas la transmission. La vaccination, c'est un effet personnel, c'est tout.
Ça réduit les effets au maximum, mais ça n'empêche pas le virus de se transmettre.
Ça diminue quand même nettement les chances d'être, de la viralité du truc quoi. La trans-- ça diminue-
Oui.
La transmission.
Oui, certes.
Dans le cas d'une pandémie, c'est un fait.
Certes, ça l'a sans doute diminué, mais aujourd'hui, et je pense que ce sont des choses que-- moi, je vous dis, je suis vacciné, je suis pas un anti-vax hein.
Clairement, non.
Mais je me demande s'il y a pas eu des conséquences que nous n'avons pas encore tout à fait déterminées ou qui ne sont pas connues par rapport aux conséquences du vaccin.
Je ne suis pas certain que nous sachions tout à cet égard.
OK. Je ne m'attendais pas à ce que nous prenions un tournant complotiste dans cette interview.
Je ne pense pas du tout parce que le complotiste suppose une volonté.
Mh.
Je n'ai pas dit qu'il y avait volonté.
Oui, oui, bah écoutez, tout-
Vous savez, dans les complotistes, il y a parfois des lanceurs d'alerte qui ont raison hein. On commence par leur dire qu'ils sont complotistes et puis après, on les remercie de leur message hein. Attention.
À propos de complotisme et de-
Oui.
Et de mouvances douteuses, nous enregistrons cette interview moins de vingt-quatre heures après la passation de pouvoir à Washington.
Mh.
On a observé un geste assez choquant de la part de l'homme le plus riche du monde. Est-ce que vous partagez avec moi le fait que on se rapproche dangereusement d'un État fasciste américain ?
Certains disent que c'est un geste qui pouvait être interprété comme ça, d'autres disent que c'est un geste qui doit être interprété comme ça.
Il faudrait peut-être un jour lui poser la question.
Alors, il a réagi sur Twitter.
Donc-
Et plutôt que de nier la question et de dire : « Non, ce n'était pas... » Donc faire référence à un salut nazi d'Elon Musk.
Plutôt que de dire : « Non, ce n'était pas ça », il a dit : « Oh, j'en ai marre de toutes ces accusations. »
Oui, bon. Vous savez, il y a des tas d'autres éléments qui vont dans ce sens par rapport à l'ambiance actuelle. Que bon, ça, c'est un petit épiphénomène.
On peut regretter l'absence de Jean-Marie Le Pen, retenu pour des raisons de santé, mais je pense qu'il aurait été très bien dans la tribune aussi.
Bien. Mais je faisais cette transition vis-à-vis de ce qu'on expliquait sur la détérioration globale de nos démocraties.
Mh.
C'est un exemple quand même assez grave. Qu'est-ce qui explique le succès de la mouvance conservatrice à travers le monde selon vous, que ce soit en Amérique, en Belgique, en France ?
La démocratie, c'est toujours malheureusement un mouvement de balancier qui va aller dans un sens, dans l'autre. Je sais pas, moi, je ne suis ni sociologue ni politologue.
Je pense que le phénomène de la crainte de la paupérisation sont deux phénomènes. La crainte venant
des déséquilibres sociaux et de la paupérisation étant les conséquences, sont à la base effectivement d'une volonté soit de voter dans l'extrême droite, soit de voter dans l'extrême gauche.
Les deux phénomènes peuvent se cumuler. L'extrême droite, malheureusement, là, elle est en train de prendre par rapport aux États-Unis quelque chose d'hallucinant.
Mh.
Mais moi, je sais jamais-- moi, j'avais toujours parié sur la réélection de Trump, même quand il était au plus bas, avec les poursuites qu'il subissait.
Moi, j'ai travaillé aux États-Unis. Donc, si vous voulez, il faut connaître les États-Unis, se rendre compte qu'y a pas que San Francisco d'un côté et New York de l'autre hein.
Entre, il y a toute l'Amérique quoi. Et l'Amérique profonde, c'est Trump.
Et San Francisco est devenu assez trumpiste aussi.
Assez trumpiste aussi. Bon, je veux dire, c'est une ville très intellectuelle aussi. Mais bon, là, c'est comme ça, c'est comme ça.
Mais alors en Europe, ça, c'est vraiment le phénomène qui grimpe. Et moi, ce qui me fait très très peur, bon déjà, Meloni qui se revêt d'un manteau de démocrate, mais je voudrais bien qu'elle ne l'ouvre pas.
Parce que ce qui est à l'intérieur, à mon avis, ne doit pas être tout à fait propre. Mais imaginez-vous ce qui va se passer en France.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer en France ? On n'est pas en train de préparer tout simplement le lit de l'extrême droite en ouvrant les portes de l'Élysée à Bardella.
J'ai un peu le sentiment que c'est cela qui est en train de se produire.
Mh.
Moi, c'est une crainte réelle que j'ai parce que Trump, j'étais certain qu'il allait se faire élire. Bardella, je sais pas.
Je pense qu'il peut encore y avoir un sursaut démocratique. La France étant quand même pour moi un des plus beaux exemples d'un pays démocratique, même un peu fort de pouvoir, certes,
une grande importance de l'exécutif, mais c'est quand même un pays avec un certain nombre de valeurs et je crains le pire à cet égard.
Mais tout dépend toujours des électeurs. J'ai bien suivi le dixième, sinistre anniversaire de Charlie Hebdo.
C'était très amusant de voir les commentaires qui se faisaient par rapport à ce qui s'était passé, etc. Donc,
tout ceci se lie avec des relents de racisme, de radicalisation, de crainte, de recul, d'avancée et finalement de continents qui s'entrechoquent aujourd'hui.
Et j'ai extrêmement peur de cela. Et c'est pas fini, y a pas que l'Europe hein, donc nous sommes pas qu'en Europe tout à fait menacés.
Les extrêmes existent déjà depuis tant d'années dans les pays. Qu'est-ce qui va se passer en Iran ? Je suis en train de travailler sur un ouvrage sur l'Iran, l'Iran d'aujourd'hui hein.
Et ce qui s'y passe est effrayant, mais est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas espérer un jour un été arabe au départ de l'Iran ?
Qui n'est pas arabe-
J'ai l'impression ça fait vingt, trente ans qu'on en voit surgir peut-être un chaque été et puis finalement, il est maté à chaque fois.
Quand est-ce que ça va se passer ? C'est peut-être ce qui retient l'Iran de faire la guerre à Israël, c'est de savoir que s'ils sortent des frontières, ils vont imploser-
Ils ont raison.
De l'intérieur, c'est possible. Mais il y a tant de choses à espérer de ce côté-là et tant d'horreurs qui se passent. À un moment, il y avait un pendu sans jugement toutes les six heures à Téhéran.
On se souviendrait aussi du maire de Téhéran qui était en visite ici avec les autorités qui l'avaient laissé venir et la presse qui était passée à côté.
C'est la communauté iranienne qui a téléphoné en disant : « Vous vous rendez compte qu'il y a le maire de Téhéran qui est à l'Union européenne, à la Commission, à la passion.
» Mais non, si. Et puis ça a pris une ampleur telle que c'est devenu un phénomène de société qui a entraîné presque la chute du gouvernement hein. Donc, c'était-
Oui.
On était à deux doigts.
C'est le ministre-
Pascal Smet.
Ouais.
Le ministre des Affaires étrangères.
Presque, presque Adjala Bible, mais finalement non.
Non, il a échappé.
Oui.
Pascal Smet vous dira que c'était un tort, que c'était sa faute, mais voilà.
Mh.
Mais je m'en moque. Je veux dire, le fait que ça s'est passé, ça, c'est ahurissant. C'est pour moi un nouveau-
Ce qu'il y a de repellant dans votre réponse, que ce soit vis-à-vis donc
de ces mouvances conservatrices, c'est gentil hein, on va carrément dire fascisantes, à travers le monde et également donc l'augmentation de la criminalité, le fait qu'on court après et que c'est de pire en pire, etc.
C'est qu'y a vraiment un fatalisme et un pessimisme en fait dans votre réponse. C'est-à-dire que vous ne savez pas vraiment expliquer pourquoi les choses s'empirent au niveau démocratique.
Vous ne savez pas si on arrivera à améliorer les choses au niveau criminel. Ça, c'est-- bon, je ne suis pas sûr que nos auditeurs et nos auditrices vont bien dormir cette nuit.
C'est ça que, c'est ça que-
Mais quand vous dites que je suis fataliste et pessimiste, je termine quand même par un mot. Mon essai, c'est le mot espérance.
Mh.
D'un autre côté, il y a quand même deux pages qui sont consacrées à un certain nombre de moyens que je souhaite voir mis en exécution pour tenter justement de lutter contre cette criminalité organisée.
Et donc, en réalité, je ne suis pas fataliste.
Bien sûr.
Mon pessimisme, mon pessimisme, il est dirigé vers, en réalité, la nature humaine du monde politique quoi.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Mais pas par rapport aux gens.
Mh.
Moi, vous savez, je suis un humaniste profond, raison pour laquelle je ne serai jamais quelqu'un de politique, c'est impossible.
Vous allez me dire que si, il y a des politiques qui sont des humanistes, je suis d'accord. Mais-
Ils ont changé de nom de métier.
Je ne pense pas que ce soit l'apanage de tout le monde politique pour cela. Bon, ben en attendant, voilà, on est quand même dans une situation extrêmement délicate, mais moi, je crois encore en cela.
Et à défaut de faire marche arrière, je pense qu'on peut, vers l'avenir, tenter de-- mais tous ces phénomènes s'agglutinent.
Ça devient-- bon, vous avez évoqué la montée de l'extrême droite et moi, j'évoque la montée de la criminalité financière et ça se mélange.
Et donc, ce qui est terriblement inquiétant, c'est qu'on est dans des phénomènes spirales actuellement dont on a vraiment perdu le contrôle.
Ça m'inquiète terriblement. Et je ne sais pas comment il faut faire pour réveiller le citoyen. On pouvait le faire à travers le vote, mais ça n'a pas donné grand-chose.
Bruxelles est devenue ingouvernable.
Mais pour des motifs communautaristes. C'est,
c'est hallucinant de voir dans quelle situation on se trouve dans Bruxelles par rapport à des règles structurelles qui ont été imposées à un certain moment et qui aujourd'hui se retournent complètement dans des effets pervers.
Vous faites référence au fait que les listes néerlandophones à Bruxelles ont un avantage numéraire par rapport aux listes francophones.
Qui ne correspond pas à la population.
Plus facile d'obtenir un siège néerlandophone. Et il y a notamment une liste électorale qui s'appelait, qui est la liste de Fuad Ahidar,
qui a fait campagne en fait sur les deux fronts, du côté francophone et chez les néerlandophones également, puisque à la base, il venait d'une-
Tout à fait.
Parti socialiste néerlandophone. Et donc, ça lui a permis d'obtenir une armée d'électeurs et qui donc lui a permis d'obtenir, alors, je ne sais plus, trois ou combien de sièges ?
Je pense que c'est plus ou moins ça, mais c'est beaucoup hein.
Oui, oui, trois-
Sur les treize néerlandophones, c'est une puissance de blocage.
Trois sièges sur les treize sièges néerlandophones à Bruxelles, c'est énorme.
C'est gigantesque.
Il y a, je crois, Groen, qui en a quatre.
Hm hm.
Donc-
Je ne sais plus les répartitions au chiffre près, mais en tout cas, la puissance de blocage, elle est là.
Voilà.
La capacité de blocage, elle est là.
Voilà. Du coup, oui, moi, je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que la seule solution viendra d'une réforme de ce système-là et qu'on n'aura pas de gouvernement avant.
Là, nous sommes bien d'accord.
Oui. Ça passera par quoi exactement ? Je ne suis pas familier avec-
Une réforme tout à fait structurelle. C'est normatif hein, donc il faut retravailler tout quoi. Mais bon, ça va entraîner aussi des levées de boucliers parce que vous passerez alors par une réduction de la représentation flamande.
Hm hm.
Ça, ils n'accepteront jamais. N'oubliez jamais que nous sommes complètement bouffés par le communautaire, qui est un problème qui est bien plus fondamental que combattre la criminalité financière et la montée de l'extrême droite.
Parce que ça, c'est grave.
Et le communautaire bloque logiquement les efforts qui pourraient aller dans ce sens-là. Et bon, donc voilà, on va mettre le communautaire de côté pour l'instant.
Aujourd'hui, la situation du David Tuerie dans les rues de Bruxelles, est-ce qu'on va vers le mieux ou bien est-ce que c'est toujours aussi grave qu'il y a un an ?
Il y a un an, j'interviewais François De Smet, qui à ce moment-là était président de Défi. Effectivement, il me parlait de, voilà, de kalachnikov facilement achetés à Anderlecht, on parlait de-
Pas de souci.
Attentats, voilà, à altitude cent, comme vous le disiez, etc. C'était juste un état de fait, un constat. J'ai pas l'impression que les choses aient beaucoup bougé en un an.
Mais la situation s'est aggravée, je veux dire.
Il y a eu malgré tout, je veux dire, un, je crois, un juge d'instruction qui a été nommé, un tribunal spécial vis-à-vis de ces questions, si je ne dis pas de bêtises. Peut-être que-
Vous parlez de la procureure, dans le cas des narcotrafiquants, madame Van Overmeire ?
Potentiellement, je ne suis plus très sûr.
Elle est chargée de la politique criminelle en matière de lutte contre les narcotrafiquants, qui est une personne remarquable.
Hm.
Mais simplement, moi, avec les moyens qu'elle a, et donc elle va obtenir des moyens parce que je pense qu'elle a cette capacité de convaincre, notamment par des solutions qu'elle apporte et que je rejoins aussi en partie.
Il y a un point sur lequel elle et moi, nous ne sommes pas d'accord, c'est la libéralisation du cannabis. Là, elle est contre, moi, je suis pour.
C'est un conflit d'idées, ce n'est pas un conflit de personnes. Mais c'est pas...
Vous savez, au contraire, vous savez que dans la lutte contre les narcotrafiquants, vous avez un juge d'instruction à Anvers qui est placé en safe house.
Vous savez ce que c'est être placé en safe house ?
C'est un bagne.
Vous êtes privé de votre vie privée. Vous allez dans une maison que personne ne connaît sauf vous et les deux membres de votre famille ou trois qui peuvent vous accompagner.
Vous êtes sous protection rapprochée minute par minute. Vous n'avez plus de vie privée, vous n'avez plus de loisirs, vous n'avez plus rien hein.
Ça fait combien de mois que ça dure hein ? Ça, c'est la réalité.
Tout ce que vous disiez-
Pour dire que ça ne s'aggrave pas, moi, je pense que ça s'aggrave terriblement.
Voilà, mais donc on expliquait pourquoi c'est bloqué au niveau budgétaire, au niveau politique communautaire à Bruxelles, etc.
Mais c'est une question qu'il faut leur poser à eux : pourquoi est-ce que vous bloquez tout ? Alors bon, on va voir l'Arizona.
Alors moi, j'attends avec impatience, effectivement, de lire ce qu'ils vont faire. Mais croyez-moi bien que c'est des questions qu'on leur posera.
Parce que maintenant, je demanderai tout simplement qu'il y ait des questions parlementaires qui soient
soumises de manière permanente,
pour voir quels sont les progrès qui vont être réalisés dans le cadre de ce combat et pourquoi, tout d'un coup, il n'y a même pas l'once de l'exécution d'une mesure qui est prise pour lutter contre les phénomènes que nous avons décrits.
On attendra que le gouvernement soit formé pour les confronter à ces questions-là.
Pour autant qu'il le soit d'ailleurs. Encore deux, trois Twitter de GLB. Je sais pas, ce serait dans une situation catastrophique.
Ils sont dans une situation catastrophique de négociation. Mais voilà, au moment où cette interview sortira, je suppose qu'on aura plus de réponses.
Oh, elle sortira dans deux jours, donc-
Ah ben non, on n'aura toujours pas de réponses.
Bien, voilà, donc on se rapproche tout doucement de la fin de cette interview. Je vais quand même revenir sur une question qu'on a rapidement évoquée en début d'interview, à savoir le Qatar Gate.
Hm hm.
Donc, on l'a évoquée rapidement hein : appartement visité, menaces de mort.
Non.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui-
Oui, oui, menaces de mort, oui. J'ai oublié. Non, j'ai reçu une lettre, deux lettres en disant : « Tu as vu l'étoile du matin se lever, tu ne verras pas l'étoile du soir se coucher », et visant une personne.
Voilà. Donc c'était assez amusant parce que quand on reçoit ce genre de lettres, ça fait rire.
Hm.
Parce que ce sont des gens qui sont un petit peu dérangés, donc voilà.
Vous n'êtes pas sous protection policière, vous n'êtes pas... Je dis une bêtise ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Ok. Sur base de ces-
Bien entendu, oui, bien sûr.
D'accord, ok. Parce que je n'ai pas vu de policiers devant chez moi. C'est pour ça que...
Ah. Ben non, pas pour l'instant. Je suis retraité, ça fait un an que j'ai quitté. Dites, on va pas poursuivre-
Ah voilà, ça.
Les personnes.
Mais vous l'avez été.
On va pas surveiller ma maison de retraite quand même.
Oui, c'est ça. Bien, mais donc pour revenir à ce que je disais, donc menaces de mort, appartement visité.
Est-ce que vous en savez plus à ce stade ?
Rien du tout.
Ouais. C'est bon, et ça, ça ne vous interpelle pas plus que ça ?
Pas plus. C'est ainsi. Je sais très bien qu'on n'obtiendra jamais la réponse, donc je vais pas m'en faire pour ça. Je m'en suis jamais inquiété d'ailleurs.
Donc, il y a quelques années, j'ai fait l'objet d'une tentative de corruption absolument spectaculaire. Et là, pendant une semaine, j'avais vraiment des policiers qui m'étaient attachés
presque vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre.
Vous dormiez avec.
Et là, c'était assez amusant parce que je vais peut-être le raconter un jour dans mes mémoires.
Vous vous amusez ?
Je crois que ça fera rire beaucoup de gens.
Vous pouvez le faire maintenant.
J'ai toujours refusé de le faire en public. Mais je vous le raconterai en privé.
Avec plaisir, je coupe les micros. Bien, est-ce que, voilà, donc, vous, le Qatar Gate, vous vous êtes in fine retiré du dossier.
Est-ce que ces pressions ont joué ou-- Je devine que non, puisque vous vous amusez très fort de mes questions à ce sujet.
Vous vous êtes retiré pas du tout vis-à-vis de ça alors ?
D'abord, je n'étais pas obligé de le faire. Ensuite, c'est parce que justice must be done and seems to be done too,
que les motifs qui étaient invoqués par quelques roquets hurlants, je ne sais plus qui, finalement, se sont avérés tout à fait faux, dans la suite de l'enquête telle que le Parquet fédéral l'a communiquée.
Vous savez, de toute façon, j'arrivais à la pension, alors que ce soit trois mois plus tard ou trois mois avant, ça ne change rien.
Ça ne sert à rien d'assassiner un juge ou de le démettre. Il y a de toute façon un autre qui suit, qui reprend et qui continue le travail.
Donc, en cela, ça ne change rien par rapport ni à l'équilibre du dossier, ni par rapport à son suivi, c'est tout.
Et le dossier, contrairement à ce qu'on pense, continue sa vie tout à fait normale, puisque actuellement, on soumet, d'après ce que je lis dans la presse, hein, je ne dévoile pas, on soumet à la Chambre des mises en accusation
la validité de l'enquête au départ la sûreté de l'État.
De deux choses l'une, c'est valide ou c'est pas valide. Et si tout d'un coup, jusqu'à la Cour de cassation, on estime que la sûreté de l'État a bien fait son job et la justice ensuite,
eh bien à partir de ce moment-là, on aura vidé les problèmes de procédure et je pense que cette affaire pourra être jugée au fond.
Vous avez une idée, une estimation du timing que ça prendrait ?
Pas du tout.
Ouais, OK. Mais donc, on...
C'est le feu du canon.
Ouais.
Vous connaissez le feu du canon ?
Mais ça-- L'affaire suit son cours.
L'affaire suit son cours.
Progresse. Y a, voilà, des magistrats belges dont la tête a été mise à prix. Ils ont reçu des menaces. Et donc aujourd'hui, vous vous sentez en sécurité ?
Tout à fait. Je ne me suis jamais senti en insécurité. C'est un sentiment,
Ouais.
Oui, il y a des gens qui prennent le métro et qui se sentent en insécurité.
Exactement. De ma vie entière, je me suis jamais senti en insécurité. Vous savez, quand j'ai enquêté au Pakistan,
en plein pays taliban, à la frontière de l'Afghanistan, en pays pachtoune, où nous étions avec des protections militaires et la voiture blindée de l'ambassadeur, etc.
Je me suis jamais senti en insécurité, mais c'était une expérience qu'il fallait vivre. L'hôtel dans lequel on est descendu d'ailleurs, six mois plus tard, a explosé.
Le deuxième hôtel aussi, l'Intercontinental et le Marriott. Il y a eu cent soixante morts, mais c'était six mois après notre venue.
Je laisse ça sans voix. Très bien. Michel Claise, merci beaucoup pour ces plus de Septante Minutes passées avec moi.
Eh bien, le temps a passé. C'était, je dirais, presque une conversation plutôt qu'une interview. Très agréable.
C'est absolument le principe. Je vous remercie et je vous dis à très bientôt. Au revoir. Merci. J'espère que ça vous a plu.
Un grand merci à lui pour ce charmant entretien. Des sujets graves et sérieux, mais abordés en toute légèreté. C'était fort sympa.
Je rappelle que son livre Combattre la criminalité, une urgence démocratique, est dispo chez Racine. On a rapidement parlé d'Alexander De Croo, qui était donc, comme je le disais, mon premier invité dans Septante Minutes Avec.
C'était en mai 2018 que j'avais enregistré cette interview. Je me souviens que Fanny Ruwet m'avait prêté son matos, emprunté en douce de l'IHECS.
Et aujourd'hui, on en est déjà au nonantième épisode de Septante Minutes Avec. Le temps passe. Comme je vous le disais il y a quelques semaines, il va bientôt y avoir des changements importants dans ce podcast et dans ce format.
Le centième épisode sera l'occasion d'opérer un tournant. Je n'en dis pas plus pour l'instant. Je n'ai pas encore de cap clair, comme diraient certains, mais ça avance et j'ai hâte de vous en dire plus.
Vous allez voir, ça va être formidable, ça, c'est certain. Je suis sur Bluesky et sur TikTok et sur Instagram, donc n'hésitez pas à me follow.
De mon point de vue, ce sont les derniers réseaux qui sont potables. Bluesky, c'est fort sympa. Ça rappelle Twitter il y a une dizaine d'années où les gens sont fort cool et fort polis.
Et il y a les journalistes. Il y a quelques politiciens, pas encore beaucoup, mais c'est pas très grave.
N'oubliez pas de laisser des étoiles sur Apple Podcast et sur Spotify. Tous les liens sont en description. Et on se retrouve très bientôt. Salut, salut !